tiziana béguines au vu de la
multiplication des tensions les
incidents et des violations de l'accord
est-ce qu'il ya encore une quelconque
valeur cet accord est ce que les
vingt-sept ont eu raison de le signer un
effet on connaissait déjà les problèmes
parce que les accords on peut les
saignées mansuy il faut les faire
respecter les faire fonctionner et on a
une histoire de beaucoup de dkd d'accord
pour martial commerciaux qui qui
fonctionne sur le papier mais mais pas
dans la réalité est là est ce que c'est
le cas et c'est le cas c'est le cas
parce que même si on a eu un compromis
parce que en effet d'un point de vue
commercial
le problème de la pêche c'est ça que
l'on parle qui ont vie augmenter les
tensions entre les deux pays sur la
manche c'est plus politique qui est de
grande valeur d'un point de vue des
échanges et de l'impact économique mais
on connaissait déjà les grands problèmes
parce que les positions étaient très
loin
au début on a ici compromis mais
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe quand
par exemple l'île de djerba ci n'est
donc pas l'essence les permis de
repêcher la bureaucratie est très lent
et on peut peut voir si c'est vraiment
comme ça où ce sont deux les mécanismes
de protection de protectionnisme de la
partie 2
des anglais dont c'est normal la
commission s'est exprimé à ce propos à
ce sujet et il faut appliquer le
le règlement ce qui en a signé ensemble
et en effet il y a des problèmes
techniques parce que c'est pour les
grands problèmes c'est non pour ce qui
concerne les pêcheurs qui ont des
bateaux petit comme ils n'ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir ces détecteurs de
placement et ses sucs empêche de donner
les licences n'a en effet pour ce ces
raisons là on peut pas appliquer la
l'accord donc c'est un je crois c'est en
signal de la difficulté qu'ils me voient
et je suis d'accord avec la collègue et
qu'on parle d'eux dans mon gouvernement
très conservatif qui essaient de se
serrer les plus sur soi même bon sur la
question vaccinale je ne peux pas dire
rien d'autre que et c'est en grand une
grande erreur parce que les virus ne
connaît pas les bords de même pas le
bord de la mer et donc si on fait pas
une lutte qu'ils soient de la planète
entière on va par avoir un résultat
alors effectivement la question de la
pêche madame cavadini avec les
l'attribution des licences aux pêcheurs
européens dans les îles anglo normandes
et des négociations qui patinent sur le
volume des espèces et en tant que verte
ça va vous parler que les pêcheurs
peuvent capturer on a quand même c'est
le sentiment que les anglais ils ont
repris le contrôle de leurs zones de
pêche et ils font un peu ce qu'ils
veulent
ok si on demande que les pêcheurs
britannique aussi sont pas satisfaits
donc ça dépend un peu c'est quand des
mondes mais moi je crois la pêche était
vraiment une
un thème très idéologique très
émotionnelle pour les pour les
britanniques et et pour les français
aussi un peu les français aussi d'accord
à pau les allemands mais aussi pour les
français m
moi je crois que c'est important de les
deux côtés vraiment faut que les règles
disent il y a maintenant des règles et
c'est vraiment important avec tout
l'accord qu on a maintenant qu' on
respecte les règles et moi aussi j'ai
l'impression qu'elle règle
c'est difficile parce que c'est pas
encore clair qu'est ce que signifie mais
on voit aussi que la grande bretagne ne
respecte quelques règles
et ça c'est un problème ça c'est
vraiment un problème parce que on voit
la situation
l'entonnoir et on a on va autre
situation et je crois que pour moi ce
que fait paul jones et de essayer de
détourner l'attention des erreurs de son
gouvernement parce qu en irlande où vous
avez raison c'est là là encore il ya un
gros problème c'est à dire que il a
décalé du 1er avril à octobre 2021 la
mise en place des contrôles sanitaires
et phytosanitaires unilatéralement sans
demander l'accord des européens ce qui
est pas dans l'accord de divorce
là ils violent encore un peu la corde du
divorce les on se laisse faire ou quoi
qu'est-ce comment ça se passe et je
crois que la situation est pas très bon
ça c'est que ça c'est clair
je crois que c'est ridicule que boston a
négocié cet accord là il a il était
d'accord
il voulait ça il maintenant ils disent
non non non je ne fais pas à faire que
ça qui est drôle d'accord donc c'est
vraiment un problème
l'union européenne a déjà commencé avec
quelques uns procédure juridique et je
crois que c'est très important que on
commence déjà démontré sa peut pas être
le cas que le royaume uni ne respectent
pas les règles ça c'est vraiment un
problème mais on voit aussi c'est pas
facile parce que johnson
même s'il ya maintenant un processus
juridique pour un smic nord ce qu'est
l'union européenne 10 et ça c'est aussi
un problème alors justement à la il ya
autre chose à la proche du 30 juin date
limite pour demander un statut de
résident un européen sur dix a choisi de
quitter le pays
le royaume uni beaucoup risquent de
basculer dans l'illégalité s'ils n'ont
pas présenté à temps leur demande de
statut de résident une situation
intolérable selon cinq ans
[Musique]